even as the wards were being counted
ahead of these preliminary results many
believe that the outcome was
predetermined
one of tunisia's most prominent
opposition figures najib shebi claims
the process of this controversial
referendum was rigged
to secure the result kai saeed dissolved
the election committee and installed his
own we questioned this committee's
independence the results announced
contradict those noted by local and
foreign observers these results are fake
and overinflated 75 percent of tunisians
refused to go to vote on kai saeed's
constitution
despite the historical low turnout of 30
percent president kassaid was quick to
claim victory
he remains optimistic that this is the
beginning of a new chapter for the
country
it will be a real democracy and not a
formality as we've had for decades the
people will recover their wealth and
whoever committed crimes against the
tunisian people must be tried
but international reaction has been
cautious
we also knew concerns that the new
constitution includes weakened checks
and balances
that could compromise the protection of
human rights and fundamental freedoms
with the results now announced tunisia
will shift from a parliamentarian system
to an executive presidential one critics
say the president will now have full
control over parliament the government
as well as the judiciary in effect this
will put an end to the separation of
power in the country tunisia was the
spark for the arab spring that spread
across the region despite its ups and
downs for the last decade it has been
regarded as the only democracy to emerge
from the upheaval but now with a new
constitution coming into effect
questions are being raised are the arab
spring goals betrayed is this the end of
the arab spring the opposition still
believes that democracy will eventually
prevail
we have no choice but democracy now it's
in a relapse but it will win we see the
algerian movement hasn't ended in
victory iraq is not doing so well but
they will eventually triumph democracy
is now engraved in the arab mindset it
will not fade look at sudan algeria
lebanon i see a future for democracy i
see a setback in countries like egypt
and syria and other nations but i also
see it making a comeback
while a silent majority has chosen to
stay away from the polling stations
chaby's optimism about the future of
democracy remains not proven
rasul sardar al-jazeera tunis